cost average american households about
five thousand dollars a year which is a
pretty significant sum when you think
about people's budgets uh since the
executive order was signed six months
ago the council's members have met every
deadline in the president's order these
actions across a broad range of
industries will bring real benefits to
american families for example the fda
has taken action to lower the cost of
hearing aids from thousands to hundreds
of dollars for the millions of americans
suffering from hearing loss it's
becoming cheaper and easier for
americans to fix the things they already
own following the executive order
support for the right to repair the ftc
will repair will ramp up enforcement
actions against illegal repair
restrictions since then big firms like
apple and microsoft voluntarily announce
changes to their policies so that
consumers can readily repair their own
phones and laptops the department of
justice the ftc and other agencies have
increased efforts to challenge or block
mergers that would leave customers with
fewer choices higher prices and lower
rate wages for example the department of
justice blocked an insurance mega merger
that would have raised insurance costs
for consumers and businesses alike so
this is part of our ongoing effort i
also wanted to share that nato is
launching a significant military
training exercise called neptune strike
22 this is something my colleague at the
department of defense updated on on
friday
but it will run through february 4th and
is designed to demonstrate nato's
high-end maritime strike capabilities
the uss harry s truman carrier strike
group will serve as the centerpiece for
this military exercise and be placed
under nato operational control this is
the first time since the end of the cold
war that a u.s carrier strike group has
gone under nato command and this
exercise will help demonstrate the unity
capability and strength of the transit
the transatlantic alliance it also
advances our ability to integrate an
aircraft carrier strike group into
nato's deterrence and defense efforts
while planning for neptune strike began
in 22 2020 long before the current
escalation of tensions
from russia's aggressive posture towards
ukraine such exercises helped the united
states and its allies enhance
interoperability and ensure readiness
for any threat against nato josh why
don't you kick us off thanks jed
two subject areas
first ukraine and russia the president
is going to have his meeting with
european counterparts
what does he plan to discuss with them
and how does he plan to address the
issue of natural gas given that 40 of
eu's natural gas imports
come from uh russia
sure well as we put out just a little
bit earlier today in guidance the
president will hold a secure video call
with european leaders as part of our
close consultation and coordination with
our transatlantic allies and partners in
response to our shared concerns over
russia's military buildup on ukraine's
borders uh during that conversation uh
we expect they will discuss diplomacy
deterrence and defense efforts and we'll
have a readout for you all afterwards
and certainly uh the uh a discussion
about uh pending uh the pending
sanctions or discussion of that uh we
would expect to be part of that as well
uh but in terms of the impact i don't
have anything more to read out for you
on that front
secondly uh for the supreme court
should race be a factor in college
admissions
well this is i think uh in in relation i
would expect to the announcement by the
supreme court about the decision to take
up uh the affirmative action case this
morning uh well we're not going to
comment on the litigation or for those
questions of course the department of
justice we strongly believe this
administration in the benefits of
diversity in higher education we take
very seriously our commitment to
advancing equity and equal opportunity
for historically underserved populations
that's why in day one the president
signs an executive order launching an
ambitious hall of government response to
center equity throughout the
government's work throughout the
department of education the
administration has provided historic
investments and support for historically
black colleges and universities tribal
colleges and universities and minority
serving institutions such as hispanic
serving institutions including nearly 21
billion dollars in cumulative support
and we have moved swiftly to protect
students civil rights and equal
opportunity including by issuing
guidance about schools obligations to
investigate and address claims of
discrimination and harassment so of
course the department of justice
they can speak to their view on the
litigation
good thanks jen has president obama made
a final decision about deploying more
troops to eastern europe
well let me give you a brief update and
i know that my colleague um john kirby
is going to be briefing shortly in about
45 minutes uh or so at the um
uh at the defense department uh we have
been uh consulting with allies and
deployments and refining plans for all
scenarios we've always said we would
reinforce our allies on the eastern
flank and those conversations and
discussions have certainly been part of
what
our national security officials have
been discussing with their counterparts
now for several weeks in fact we've
never
ruled out the option of providing
assistance additional assistance in
advance of an invasion
those discussions have been ongoing with
our our partners and eastern flank
countries and again i would expect that
my colleague john kirby would have more
of an update on where the process is at
this point in time so he'll make it john
kirby will make an announcement about
whether or not he's made a decision you
know i think he will make he will
provide an update on where things stand
on those discussions so last week
president biden at the press conference
said that the u.s would fortify nato
allies but said it was dependent on an
invasion saying if he would send more
troops to poland romania if ukraine if
putin did invade ukraine so the fact
that he's considering this now and
having these discussions with pentagon
leaders over the weekend does that
suggest that he believes an invasion is
imminent we've never actually ruled out
uh providing additional support uh
additional support uh assistance uh two
eastern flank countries in advance of
any invasion and those discussions with
them have been ongoing uh and certainly
that's been part of our contingency
planning i guess the question is it does
appear to be a shift in his thinking and
his attitude toward it is that how you
would characterize it i wouldn't
characterize it that way uh we have
spoken to the fact that um and we've put
out a lot of information about uh our
view of the preparations being made by
president putin and the russians while
we can't get into the mine of president
putin we are seeing the preparations
that they're making at the border we
have been very clear and the president
has been direct that military action by
russia could come at any one at any time
he said that last week as well so uh we
have been in conversations and
discussions with eastern flank countries
obviously our secretary of state just
returned from a trip to europe as well
he was part of the discussions this
weekend too uh and part of that has been
contingency planning and discussing what
their needs have been my last question
is today the president has this call
with european leaders
several of them are on this uk france
germany italy poland nato the european
council why is ukraine not on that call
this afternoon
well we have a range of conversations
with ukrainians obviously our secretary
of state met with them last week and
they will be a part of many
conversations moving forward as i noted
a little bit earlier part of this is a
discussion about deterrence and defense
efforts diplomacy but certainly they
will be a part of many conversations as
they have been from the beginning
um
so
what happened then in the last few days
that prompted
the pentagon to present specific
potential troop deployments to the
president put another way
why now
well i wouldn't say we're characterizing
it exactly that way the president has
said said last week and we also said
that uh as we've been watching uh the
preparations of president putin and the
russians that they were prepared at any
moment to take military action uh we've
also been in ongoing discussions from
our secretary of state to members of our
national security team with our eastern
flank partners about what their needs
are and what security concerns they have
so
i wouldn't say it's a response to an
abrupt moment it's a part of an ongoing
contingency planning process and
discussion after this weekend is he more
or less concerned
about the possibility of a russian
invasion of ukraine well he said last
week that military action by russia
could come at any time
that
that remains his point of view
and um
there's been
clamoring in this town and over in
ukraine for us ambassador
to ukraine where do things stand on
appointing somebody certainly understand
that i don't have any update on the
status at this point in time the
ukrainian farm industry says the
decision to draw down the u.s presence
and kiev at the embassy
was quote premature and a manifestation
of excess caution
is this potentially in the afterglow of
what happened in afghanistan concern for
that or is something else
more specific prompting people well i
would say that we
our state department regularly reviews
and assesses what steps need to be taken
for the security of our personnel i
would note that the travel advisory was
already a level four since back in
october we've also been closely
consulting and keeping ukrainians
abreast i would say this is more akin to
what we the steps we took in ethiopia
and kazakhstan uh than any other country
or conflict
on that one other subject the house
speaker today has requested a bipartisan
all members briefing
on the situation in ukraine of the white
house is that something you guys plan to
uh fulfill uh we have been in close
consultation with members in leadership
from the beginning i don't have any
update on this specifically but that's
been our objective and how we have
proceeded so i'm sure we are working to
meet the requests and needs of members
of some news reports it looks as if at
least jake sullivan maybe others are
talking to senior lawmakers about this
and we have been for weeks
on another subject another violent
weekend across the country there was a
shooting in new york there was a
shooting here in dc of a police officer
there have been reports of a possible
executive actions that the president
might be able to take in the realm of
police reform or police policy where do
things stand on that
well
soon
let me can i may i address this weekend
first and i will come around to your
question but i think you had a few in
there important ones to address uh the
events of this weekend are reminder
that law enforcement officers head into
harm's way every single day they and
their families make an extraordinary
sacrifice
for their communities the president is
never going to be satisfied or
complacent when officers are being
gunned down or when americans have to
worry about whether they can safely ride
the subway or bus or even be at work
we've seen a surge in crime obviously
this weekend is a glaring example of
that especially gun violence over the
last two years and the president has
been aggressive in using the tools at
our disposal to combat that that's why
he took early action on gun
gun violence last spring and that's why
he rolled out a comprehensive plan to
combat crime last summer he also
believes as many americans do
that we can and must have a criminal
justice system that both protects public
safety and upholds our founding ideals
of equal treatment under law that's why
he not only has implemented this
comprehensive plan to combat crime but
why he is continuing to advocate for
reforms to our policing system he thinks
that we can do both but i don't have an
update on any timings for next step on
that go ahead thanks first on the
markets does the president think it's a
big deal that today the dow jones is
down
at one point more than 1100 points well
to start with we focus on the trends in
the economy not any one day and any
single indicator unlike his predecessor
the president does not look at the stock
market as a means by which to judge the
economy i would note uh that the market
is up around 15 compared to when
president biden took office uh but our
measure of success is really how real
working families are doing whether they
have a little breathing room whether
they have a job that delivers some
dignity in a paycheck that can support
they can support a family on and we've
seen a great deal of progress made on
that front thank you on schools in
virginia seven districts representing
350 000 students are suing the state
they're hoping to get a strict mass
mandate for students that has been
rolled back by the new governor
reinstated so who does the president
think knows best
for
students school board members or parents
well the parent the president believes
that uh public health officials have the
best guidance
on what we can all do to protect
ourselves including teachers
administrators and students it's always
been up to local school districts to
determine how they're going to approach
what implementation measures they're
going to put in place but here's what we
know from public health officials who
are the experts on a pandemic
studies show that mass reduced
transmissions in school they are a
proven tool that helps keep students and
teachers safe from covid and they can
thus help keep schools open and safe in
short we know it works and we need every
leader to focus on using the tactics we
know work to keep our students safe and
our schools open i know you mentioned
virginia but in texas the state is
fighting a critical public health
measure to protect our children and keep
our schools safely open for head start
communities
ones that a a provision that is
requiring mass to keep students and keep
communities safe they're fighting
against that why is that i think that
has uh that has more to do with politics
than it does with public health but
right now in virginia the law is now
that there's a new governor but students
should not have to wear masks if their
parents say that they don't think they
need to wear masks so if
a parent wants to send their school
their kid to school with no mask should
that child be allowed to go to school
and be in class again
we're what we're advising school
districts on is to abide by public
health guidelines and follow public
health guidelines and it's about keeping
an entire community safe and those are
the decisions that are being uh that
people should focus on making just so
that it's crystal clear for anybody
watching you guys think
that ultimately in this conflict between
school board members and parents the
school board members
should have more of a say in what what
is actually not what i said i think
everybody should abide by public health
guidelines not just to keep their own
kids safe but keep their their school
community safe whether it's teachers
classmates uh administrators others in
schools okay on crime to follow up on
what ed was asking about
would you agree that the most important
job for any president is to keep
americans safe
i would agree
so he said that the president's never
satisfied if people don't feel safe does
he know that after a year in office
people do not feel safe in this country
well peter i think if we look at the
facts here we have seen a surge of crime
over the last two years would you agree
with that
so what are you attributing the rising
crime to then well i think we should be
responsible in how reporting to the
public what the what the what the uh
roles are what the reasons for the surge
in crime gun violence is a huge reason
for the surge in crime
uh under funding of some police
departments and their need for
additional resources something the
president has advocated for consistently
through the course of his career that's
something we know we need to take action
on and it is absolutely true that he
will not be satisfied
or complacent when officers are being
gunned down or when americans have to
worry about whether they can safely ride
the subway or bus that should not be a
political issue he's somebody who has
had a long career of many decades of
fighting for
funding for police departments for local
communities in order to reduce crime but
he's been here in office for more than a
year and the murder rate is nearing a 25
year high so why don't we see and hear
more from the president
about this we hear all the time about
things that you guys are doing to fight
the pandemic because that is a risk to
american people
a rising murder rate is a risk to
american people too right and he has
spoken to crime but i think what people
are most uh focused on as they should be
are what actions he has taken he has
unveiled a strategy to focus federal law
enforcement resources on combating
violent crime offered unprecedented
levels of funding through the rescue
plan for cities and states to put more
cops on the beat and invest in proven
community anti-violence programs
something every republican voted against
the department of justice has announced
139 million dollars in grants to cities
for community policing which will put
1 000 more officers on the streets he's
also proposed doubling those grants and
he's called for an additional 750
million dollars for federal law
enforcement he's announced a zero
tolerance policy for gun dealers who
sell willfully uh willfully sell illegal
guns and we've launched gun trafficking
strike horses in new york and cities
across the country actions are important
here and he has a long record of them
but does the president think that any of
that is working
the president thinks she should have a
plan to address crime and gun violence
he has one and we look forward to
working with people who support that
effort at the murder rate nears a 25
year high would he consider maybe trying
something different
trying something other than
supporting a massive plus up in funding
from his predecessor cracking down on
gun trafficking and gun violence which
is a major driver of the violence we've
seen across the country working to
support community policing programs and
police departments across the country i
think most people who want to fight
crime would agree that's the right
approach
go ahead go ahead justin
thanks jim um just i know uh kirby's
breaking later but just a bit of a finer
point do you have any information about
how many troops are under consideration
what the time frame for the president's
decision are sort of the logistical
details were possible i don't have any
more details from here other than to
convey that we're in close consultation
with eastern flank countries about their
security needs and again we've always
said we would support them uh we've
never said that uh that that that an
invasion would be a prerequisite for
that do you expect the written response
that you're putting together to include
any requests or demands from the u.s
side including um
you know a time frame for president
couldn't start drawing down troops
i don't have anything to preview in
terms of what a written proposal would
be i would just note because we've
talked about this a bit that written
proposals have been the basis of
basically every agreement we've ever had
with the russians in many countries
around the world they're a standard part
of diplomacy and they're they're a
format for providing areas we're
conveying areas where you have concern
and also pro but also outlining areas
where you can work together but i don't
have anything to preview on what that
would look like um
we didn't have a chance last week to
talk about uh one part of the
president's press conference where
uh he said he'd like to be in a position
to lift um
to say that china is meeting its
commitments and therefore be able to
lift of the tariffs i'm wondering when
he said that did he mean
making good on the phase one commitments
that have already been out there and
china's not meeting those or does he
mean
additional commitments that you'd be
asking for
i think he meant he's looking forward to
getting some recommendations uh through
the review process that's ongoing and
then one last one there was an fbi raid
last week on representative uh
um
reportedly over his ties to
azerbaijani oil executives i know you're
not going to comment on an ongoing
investigation but do you think that the
congressman should step away from his
committee assignments or congressional
work while this investigation i'm just
not going to have any comment on this at
this point go ahead a couple
more on ukraine uh jen uh there's a
proposal that's floating in the the juma
that would ask um vladimir putin to
recognize the donyesk and luhansk
regions of ukraine as
independent um
if uh putin does that would you regard
that as an escalation
um i have not spoken with our national
security team about that uh you know our
view on uh the sovereign the integral
the sovereign the sovereignty uh of
ukraine um and uh you know i don't have
any other comment on it though at this
point in time okay um under what
circumstances would we evacuate american
citizens and diplomats from
ukraine and can that be done without the
us military
uh well i think the reason that the
state department uh issued the guidance
they did which again is a standard
process that that the state department
um ish does uh in
reg regularly with a range of countries
where we have security concerns was to
make very clear uh that um we that
american citizens our recommendation is
that u.s citizens currently in ukraine
consider departing now using commercial
other privately available transportation
options use the online form and our
updated travel advisor to tell us their
plans so they can best conduct our
ongoing contingency planning and
register in step to ensure they receive
alerts and guidance from the state
department
we are uh we are there is not an
intention uh for there to be a departure
or an evacuation of along those lines uh
so we are conveying to american citizens
they should leave now
and in fact that there's not there's not
precedent beyond afghanistan for that to
be how it operates and then just more
broadly and for years nato members have
fallen short of their uh defense
spending uh commitments uh last year
more than 60 percent of the alliance's
30 members including half of the
bucharest nine that are right uh near
russia there um failed to meet that uh
their two percent gdp spending
commitment um if europeans aren't
willing to expend uh blood and treasure
on their self-defense why should
americans be expected to do so well we
are continuing to advocate for
um all members to uh reach uh the two
percent goal that has been the by the
president's position since he was the
vice president um so for many years now
uh i would say that uh we have a sacred
obligation under nato uh and we believe
it is also in our interest to support
our eastern flank countries uh and and
their security and also to be clear
about uh the uh the value we have as
americans which is that no country
should be able to take with force
um another country as as russia is
attempting to do at this point in time
one last one um you said that military
incursions by russia into ukraine would
trigger stiff economic sanctions um does
that apply to our policy with china um
and taiwan
as it relates
is it was a military inversion of some
kind into taiwan would there be economic
sanctions could china expect that i i
don't have anything to preview on this
that at this point in time go ahead
uh thanks jeff so at the press
conference last week the president spoke
a lot about buildback better and his
thoughts about sort of where the sweet
spot might be to to save as much of that
as he can
i think the next day senator manchin was
asked if he had spoken with the
president who said he hadn't yet has
there been any conversation direct
conversation between the president and
senator manchin since last week
we're just not going to speak to or
confirm any conversations the president
has with members of the senate moving
forward broadly
give us a sense when those conversations
will sort of ramp up in earnest
president's been in touch with a range
of senators we're just not going to
outline those or confirm those
specifically
on putting that together getting it
through the senate with 50 votes is
state of the union more or less the soft
deadline or is this something that may
well extend beyond that we haven't set a
deadline i think
what our objective is and what the
president's objective is is to
uh to move forward uh on uh on uh
you know an effort in congress in the
senate to lower costs for the american
people do that without raising the
deficit pay for it
make sure we're easing the burden that
families have across the country we need
50 votes to do that but uh that is we
don't have we have not set a deadline
let's ask you one other thing about
infrastructure you may have seen our
story and reporting elsewhere about
republican lawmakers who oppose the
bipartisan infrastructure law uh out in
the states over the recess
touting the benefits taking credit in
some cases for doing that i know that
this is a big pillar of the democrats
2022 midterm argument um and the
president's uh case for a successful
first year he's touted the bipartisan
nature of this is he going to
take issue with any of the republicans
who are out there i mean he's going to
call them out for
for saying that you know they should get
credit for something that they opposed
or is he going to let that slide well i
would say we we welcome uh the uh
the a number of republicans who voted
against the infrastructure bill coming
around to recognize the impact on their
communities we've seen
this playbook before so perhaps it
shouldn't come as a surprise
and i don't think i can stand up here
and rule out what the president is or
isn't going to call out moving forward
go ahead hey john
the president spoke last week about
russia's historic concerns about loss of
empire encirclement so my question is if
you're sending some thousands of u.s
troops to the baltics or the eastern
flank is there a chance that that will
increase the risk of war rather than
reducing
well we've had troops in the eastern
flank countries for decades
right
it sounds like what's being discussed is
sending war right now at a time of
retention and we have a sacred
obligation to support the security of
our eastern flank countries i think it's
important to remember who the aggressor
is here it is not the united states it
is not these eastern flank countries uh
it is russia who has tens of thousands
of troops on the border of ukraine they
have the power to de-escalate we would
certainly welcome that and i know both
you the president spoke about little
green men uh yeah infiltrators into the
country now that the british have put
out intelligence of a possible coup
uh planned by moscow in ukraine how
would u.s respond if that happened would
that trigger these same sanctions that
we're talking about here well i'm i'm
not going to get into intelligence
matters of course we've been warning
about russian tactics like this for
weeks uh reports of this kind of
planning are deeply concerning if acted
upon would constitute a severe
escalation and certainly there would be
consequences and then just one more on
the scad i know we've all been
anticipating the president's going to
hit the road is the reason there's
nothing on the public schedule these
tensions are involving ukraine or
another reason we i expect we'll have
some travel very very soon we're just
looking to finalize the details
go ahead kimberly thanks a couple of
questions first quick housekeeping
question have you confirmed that katari
amir will be coming to the white house
at the end of the month
and if the discussions will center
around energy supply to europe
i know there's been discussion of that i
don't have final confirmation of it i
will work to see if we can get that to
you after the briefing okay perfect and
then um as the administration weighs
reinstating the terrorist designation on
the houthis
is the president concerned this could
block humanitarian aid and
why would the president consider this if
millions are at risk of losing
assistance given his policy of upholding
human rights
well uh let me first say that we call on
all parties to uh in to the conflict to
de-escalate abide by their obligations
under international humanitarian law to
ensure the protection of all civilians
and participate fully in an inclusive
un-led peace process all parties must
commit to a peaceful diplomatic solution
to ending the conflict and advance a
durable resolution that improves the
lives of yemenis and allows them to
collectively determine their own future
there have been dangerous escalations in
in days which is of course why you were
asking these escalations only exacerbate
a dire humanitarian crisis and the
suffering
of the yemeni people uh we are deeply
concerned by these reports and we are
continuing to engage at a diplomatic
level and uh in our special envoy lender
king reaffirmed or unwavering commitment
he has been recently on the ground uh
pressing parties for de-escalation and
protection for civilian lives
quickly a uk court is now allowing
julian assange to appeal his extradition
to the united states the justice
department as you know isn't commenting
but what about the president he says
press freedom is critical for democracy
so why is he continuing to pursue this
case
is the reason that
he's pursuing this trump-era case
because
julian assange embarrassed the
democratic party in 2016.
again this is uh under the purview of
the demo the department of justice uh so
i don't have any comment from here
good thank you on the palin new york
times case i know you can't maybe speak
specifically to the case but does the
white house have any concerns about
threats to press freedoms first access
to the limits of the first amendment
protection
i obviously can't speak to the case i
appreciate you saying that at the top i
i will say that i think the president
has shown that he uh
respects uh the value of the freedom of
the press uh he obviously took a step
earlier this year to ensure there
couldn't be a replication of actions
that had been taken over prior
administrations as it related to uh
journalists um so i think that speaks to
his commitment but i don't have any more
comment on the case and then uh
following off of it i know you guys have
forecasted potentially policing reform
executive action some uh civil rights
advocates also want to see
additional voting rights executive
actions is there anything
any details or any timeline for what you
think the president the white house may
do there considering that it's stalled
in congress
well uh you know the president is going
to keep fighting until his last breath
as you as you've heard him say on voting
rights because he thinks it's so vitally
important um we did do an executive
order early on in the administration
which was quite extensive and
comprehensive that is still being
implemented in terms of additional
executive orders that would be possible
that we have the authority to do i don't
have anything to predict on along those
lines but we are going to continue to
fight to get federal legislation passed
we are going to continue to work with
states uh to ensure that uh there is
proper protections uh and uh there is of
course uh more work ahead
go ahead uh yes uh there are currently
at least 150 uh american military
advisors in ukraine including members of
the florida national guard uh are those
soldiers going to remain in ukraine are
there contingency plans if hostilities
break out to remove them what's their
disposition
i would point you to the department of
defense to ask them that question okay
uh my colleague mentioned afghanistan
and one of the things that you hear
among
russian propaganda in ukraine is that
the united states is an unreliable ally
that is using ukraine as a pawn and they
point to the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan as evidence that the united
states cannot be counted on how does the
united states respond to that and has
the afghanistan withdrawal complicated
diplomacy in this regard
uh it is not in our experience that we
the president ended a 20-year war uh in
afghanistan something he had talked
about consistently doing for some time
as he was running for president and even
before then i think our commitment to
our nato partners is clear
our commitment to ukrainians is clear
we've sent more security assistance over
the last year than in any year in recent
history we've been in constant contact
as evidenced by the president's call
this afternoon with our european
partners as we work uh to ensure we're
in lockstep as we approach the next
stage and anticipate what president
putin may or may not do
so what i would say to that is that
sounds like the old russian propaganda
playbook uh something we've talked about
in the past and i'd encourage anyone to
be mindful of that and finally there's
negotiations going on in congress for
russian sanctions if they do take
military action against ukraine does the
united states support congress acting
and are they involved in this
negotiation
we are keeping we are regularly updating
and briefing leaders in congress
and about what steps are under
consideration what the status is of
things we're seeing on the ground
obviously we've talked about a lot of
this publicly as well uh and we've also
been clear that we have a uh a severe uh
sanctions package of economic options
that is under consideration should they
decide to invade we also recently
sanctioned a couple of individuals for
their engagement as well uh but i don't
have anything uh in terms of these
specific steps under consideration we
have our own severe steps that we are
considering here and we're keeping
congress abreast of that have congress
involved
well we're we're working in lockstep
with them we are briefing them we are uh
conveying to them what we're thinking
about and considering um and of course
getting feedback from them as well
um go ahead i i recognize that the white
house has said that they have you know
very severe sanctions that are prepared
if russia invades is there any thought
to
enacting sanctions before russia invades
as a form of deterrence or is is that
under consideration well we did announce
a couple of sanctions sets of sanctions
from the treasury department last week
uh in response to their uh the
involvement of a few individuals we've
also plused up our security assistance
packages that we've been delivering to
the ukrainians including recent
deliveries over the last couple of days
and obviously as we were talking about
earlier in this briefing there's been
discussions about how we can
support the security of eastern flank
countries but also we are mindful of
what we think is the most effective
deterrent and the severe economic
sanctions packages something that would
be uh go far beyond what was done and
what was on the table in 2014 including
the consideration of imposing
unprecedented export control
measures that would hit hard at
president putin's ambitions are part of
the discussion and our assessment is
that is most effective as
a
deterrent tool and not as one we would
do in advance
okay so you're saying the threat of the
sanctions is the most effective
deterrent correct
i have a question just to follow up i
know that you know you were asked about
americans who are now in ukraine i know
you said that
there is no precedent you know outside
of afghanistan for evacuations and if
there was like some type of military
encouragement by the russians so i just
want to be clear if americans are still
in ukraine and things start happening
with russia
are they pretty much on their own
well we are conveying very clearly now
that now is the time to leave and that
there are means to do that of course
there's commercial airlines you can
depart over land there's obviously the
embassy there to provide assistance and
this is very similar to what we did in
ethiopia kazakhstan and many other
countries over the course of the last
several decades but there is not an
intention or a plan for any military
evacuation and just quickly um in the in
the past um a call another call
with putin was still on the table i
believe that the president was supposed
to talk with his advisers about that uh
this weekend look what have any
decisions been made about that will
there be another call or another talk
with putin
the president uh remains open to leader
to leader diplomacy of course he knows
how effective that can be uh but i don't
have anything to predict or preview at
this point in time in terms of a call
between them
oh hold on let me just get to the last
two and then i'll come back around go
ahead the president said last week that
he has basically on a daily basis to
work to keep unity in nato and how
unified our nato partners if it comes to
hard and meaningful sanctions against
russia and
what is the president's assessment or
the white house's assessment of the new
german chancellor in that case
well i know that my uh that our
secretary of state spoke to this um just
yesterday and what i would note is that
um as he said uh that we're confident
the germans share our concerns and are
prepared to respond swiftly effectively
in a united way to russian aggression
against ukraine germany is one of our
closest allies in fact we look forward
of course to welcoming the chancellor
here uh to the united states in february
um the germans have said as you know
that if russia further invades ukraine
the for the future nordstrom 2 the
future of nordstrom 2 would be in grave
jeopardy this is real leverage over
putin if putin wants to see gastle
through the pipeline he cannot invade
ukraine the pipeline is of course not
operational but that is often the
context of how this question is asked i
think what the president was conveying
is that it doesn't happen on its own it
requires work it requires conversations
it requires face-to-face diplomacy i
think there's been over a hundred
engagements that senior members of his
national security team and the president
have taken a part of part in in order to
ensure that we are united and strong as
we uh as we uh confront the the threats
posed by president putin did germany
need more work than other nato partners
and i would say germany remains one of
our key partners and allies uh and again
we are working in lockstep with them go
ahead yes
uh senator susan collins is leading a
working group looking at performing the
electoral count act so that during the
accounting of the electoral college the
vice president could not reject one
slave electors and say
recognize the rival slave supporting a
rival candidate i'm just wondering
whether the white house has talked to
either senator collins or any other
senators about this and given shall we
say recent history whether the president
supports reforming the electoral crime
act well we've never said we were
opposed to it uh we are in touch with a
range of senators i'm not going to
detail who uh but across the board from
see
through senior members of uh the
legislative team senior advisors to the
president
about a range of steps that can be taken
what's important to note and i've said
in the past but i'll just reiterate it
that it does not take the place of is
not a replacement for the john lewis
voting rights act or any of the voting
rights federal legislation we were
working to get across the finish line
because they do entirely different
things including creating a baseline for
what the american people should it
should expect and frankly demand in
terms of what kind of access they should
have to participate in the voting
process and of course the
the requirement that any states that has
a history of voter suppression would
have to get approval from the department
of justice in order to change voting
laws the electoral count act doesn't do
that but we are open to the
conversations we've been participating
in the conversations but it's it's it's
not a replacement for
on a different subject so much of the
public discourse about so-called havana
syndrome
has come from anonymous leaks and i'm
just wondering how soon will the
national security council release their
expert report on havana syndrome and
are these anomalous health incidents and
will this report be made
you know public in a full subway
sure well i know there's been a recent
cia report um that talks about the
findings of their interim analysis it
does not which does not rule out that a
foreign actor may be involved in a
subset of reported cases and affirms
that the intelligence community
will be drilling down in its analysis on
a subset of cases um the toughest
unresolved ones of course to try to
determine whether a foreign actor may be
involved there are a range of
investigations
and efforts underway across the us
government and we continue to take every
port of a suspected incident uh safely
what's most important is the president
has asked has asked his national
security team to ensure we are leaving
no stone unturned and ensuring that
people who have been impacted receive
the proper health care they need i can't
make a prediction of what a final
release of a report would look like i
would really point you to the
intelligence community on that there's
one last one
just yesterday in dc not far from here
actually there was an anti-mask
rally where you know some of the
rhetoric around that was talking about
nuremberg style trials to to you know
hold anthony fauci to account to go
after the media for spreading lies
things like this i'm just wondering how
the administration is going to respond
to what appears to be a growing
intensity and potential for violence in
the anti-tax movement
well we we are well aware that there is
a loud and vocal minority uh empowered
through social media and media platforms
that proliferate disinformation
politicians who espouse conspiracy
theories and fundraise off of opposition
to public health we know that we also
know that 87 of american adults have at
least one shot that's the vast vast
majority
and over 210 million americans are fully
vaccinated so our view is that it's
wrong it's dangerous and it stands in
the way of a coordinated effort to save
more american lives
25 percent of the number of closer to 25
have their booster right you feel like
you guys are sort of losing the war when
it comes to the messaging on the
importance of these type of public
health measures like getting vaccinated
again our view is that it's a loud and
vocal minority but still dangerous uh
still problematic the fact that 87 of
american adults
all of those people of course
mathematically did not vote for joe
biden um have had at least one shot
means we far surpassed where i think
most people think we would be it's
difficult and challenging of course to
get more people vaccinated we know that
um and of course efforts that are
dangerous and wrong by groups like this
are problematic as is the spread of
misinformation on social media platforms
unfortunately out of the mouths of some
uh prominent officials all of that is
problematic and harmful but again i
think we should be mindful of the large
percentage of people that have had one
shot
75 percent have had two shots obviously
our effort has been to get more people
boosted but if you're starting the
process that's a good sign
you have to
follow us
just two more details on ukraine was
there something specific that prompted
today's meeting with those
european leaders it was it's a part of
our ongoing contingency planning and
discussions about uh what we are seeing
uh but also how we can help protect and
support their security as well it wasn't
like the intelligence report from the
british over the weekend or something
prompted everybody to get together no
part of ongoing contingency discussions
and obviously he gets briefed on this in
his daily intelligence briefing we know
he had this briefing over the weekend
david can you give us any more detail or
sense of how often he's
the president's being briefed on ukraine
who's doing it uh is he asking for
updates every hour you know give us some
sense of what's going on
on this issue sure um i can tell you um
from being in a lot of meetings with him
that are unrelated to ukraine as well
that he is often asking for updates um
and looking for updates from his
national security team on where things
stand how conversations are going and
that's something he regularly asks for
he's seeing his team or members of his
team every day of course there are
central members that you're very
familiar with who participate in the pdb
jake sullivan and others and of course
he's regularly talking with us our
secretary of state who has been uh front
and center in the diplomatic efforts
thanks everyone
visit
[Music]
you